well George Lucas is a friend of mine
and he and I were having a good
conversation the other day about it
nothing will stand in our way
finish what you started
I also have a lot of respect for JJ
Abrams and I want to see where they're
taking it next you know see what they're
see what they're doing with it
do some horse that's not how the force
works I have to say that I felt that
George's group of six films had more
innovative visual imagination I am
father yes James Cameron is sticking by
his friends original vision leading many
to read between the headlines that the
oscar-winning director was throwing
shade at the force awakens director JJ
Abrams
the Star Wars universe in avatars
virtual world will most likely go to
battle at the box office in the coming
years with avatar 2 scheduled for
December 2018 release and if all goes as
planned more films will follow in 2020
2022 and 2023 outstanding and while
James did show his true team Lucas
feelings he's still waiting to give his
final opinion the garbage will do this
film was more of a retrenchment to
things you had seen before and
characters you see before and it took a
few baby steps for new characters so for
me the jury is out I want to see where
they go